when something bothers you pull it out  and look at and say what happened and  why is this bad and what would it look  like if it were good the two tools that  I use are time and volume the volume  example is thinking okay I'm in traffic  if this happened every day would I be  upset if it happened every day I'd  probably expect it which means that I  would not be upset about it because it's  just how things always are and so then  our expectation meets reality or if you  want to make it positive you say well  what if every time I got in a car  normally it would take an hour and today  it took 30. I'd be pretty excited about  it and so all we did is just change the  volume on the circumstance to  recalibrate the meaning that we're  choosing to ascribe to it good or bad